maksim now Monday night he had a verbal
smackdown with guest judge Julianne
Hough and do you think it's over yeah I
guess again we have Mad Max today in New
York
max strikes back you can accuse me of a
lot of things you can't accuse me of not
working hard enough and you just had to
phone it in with Julianne telling me
that I look like I phoned this week in
it's so absurd the confrontation
exploded on social media with many
actually supporting max and wandering of
Julianne was taking sides since her
brother Derek is his competition that
this end result Monday night product was
not a result of 15 minutes of me phoning
it in it was a result of you know four
or five hours a day of rehearsals she
said it then she now has to own up to it
but will max own up to having anger
management issues we showed the 34 year
old his history of outbursts we wanted
to know if it was for the show is it for
real or is it a problem i'ma go outside
because I'm about to punch something not
in a wall I really don't have a passion
to you know say something that ends up
in the news next day
[Music]